Saying the quiet part out loud has been sort
of a theme of the Trump administration and
a huge cause of the constant self-inflicted
damage that Donald Trump has done to himself
has come from saying things out loud or tweeting
things that he would probably be better off
keeping to himself.
And it has unfortunately happened again.
And in conjunction with the release of his
new book called Rage.
Investigative journalist Bob Woodward has
released audio of conversations that he had
with Donald Trump during which a lot of things
happen.
But making huge headlines is Donald Trump
admitting that he publicly was not telling
the truth about Corona virus as early as February
for political reasons.
Now there's debate as to whether they are
good political reasons or bad political reasons.
I would argue it doesn't matter that Donald
Trump was deceiving the public and it wasn't
a matter of national security.
It was Donald Trump wanting it to appear as
though he had things under control when he
did not.
Let's go first to the clip and then we will
discuss it.
Donald Trump admitting to Bob Woodward that
at the time, February 7th, his belief about
Corona virus was that it was very serious,
even airborne, although publicly, even four
months after this.
Donald Trump never acknowledged Corona virus
being as dangerous as he admits in this clip.
Now it's turning out.
It's not just old people, but just today and
yesterday, some startling facts came out as
not just old old people to plenty of young
people.
So what is going on?
Give me a moment of talking to somebody going
through this with Foushee or somebody who
kind of it caused a pivot in your mind, because
it's clear just from what's in on the public
record that you went through a pivot on this,
too.
Oh, my God.
The gravity is almost inexplicable and unexplainable.
Well, I think, Bob, really, to be honest here,
I want you.
I wanted to I wanted to always play it down.
I still like playing it down.
Yes.
Because I don't want to create a panic.
So there it is.
It's plain as day.
Now, what is the response going to be?
I'll tell you what it is.
It's not going to be that the audiotapes have
been doctored because they clearly have not.
The argument is going to be.
Not wanting people to panic is something good
that Donald Trump does, and it's something
that he has done in general during his presidency,
of course.
It is not true when it comes to the immigrant
caravan.
Donald Trump's strategy was create as much
panic as possible, make people think things
are as dangerous as possible, even when they
are not.
When it comes to Joe Biden's America, the
strategy is.
We want people to panic because it's politically
advantageous.
So there are people I don't know that they're
all bad faith actors, but they certainly are
making nonsense arguments who are saying this
isn't bad.
This is Trump saying, hey, I don't want the
country panicking.
So I am going to do what I need to prevent
the country from panicking because panic would
be bad.
That's not what this is.
Donald Trump has no problem with the country
panicking when it is politically advantageous.
Now, there's other clips here in this next
clip.
Trump is talking to Bob Woodward again.
And Donald Trump continues to acknowledge
that the virus is airborne and it's far more
dangerous than Donald Trump ever admitted.
And so what was President Xi saying yesterday?
Well, we were talking mostly about the virus,
and I think he's going to have it in good
shape.
But, you know, it's a very tricky situation.
It's it goes it goes through air, but it's
always tougher than the touch.
Another touch.
You don't have to touch things.
Right.
But the air, you just breathe the air.
That's how it's passed.
And so that's a very tricky one and that's
a very delicate one.
It's also more deadly than your you know,
your even your strenuous flus.
You know, people don't realize when there's
25000, 30000 people a year.
Who would ever think that, right?
I know.
I mean, it's pretty amazing.
And then I say, well, as I do the same thing
for this is more deadly.
This is five per you know, this is five percent
versus one percent and less than one percent.
So this is deadly stuff.
Now, at the time when Trump said this to Bob
Woodward publicly, Trump was saying it's like
a seasonal flu.
It's going to disappear.
Fifteen cases will soon be zero.
It is a straight up lie.
The only debate is whether the lie was justified.
For some reason, I think the answer is clearly
no.
Other interesting things asked by Bob Woodward
whether racism is here in the United States
in a way that affects people's lives.
Donald Trump replied, I think it is, and I
think it's unfortunate, but I believe it is.
Again, I think there is systematic or institutional
racism in this country.
Well, I think there is everywhere.
I think probably less here than most places
are, unless you know that many places.
OK.
But is it here in a way that it has an impact
on people's lives?
I think it is and it's unfortunate, but I
think it is so Trump admitting there something
that, again, he has refused to acknowledge
publicly.
And overall, this is a wild book, all sorts
of stunning material from Bob Woodward.
We're going to talk later about the report
in this book that Donald Trump's former secretary
of defense, Jim Mattis, said to the director
of National Intelligence, Dan Coats, that
they may need collective action to remove
Donald Trump.
We're going to talk later about whether Bob
Woodward had a responsibility to make some
of these elements public sooner than he did.
We're going to get to all of that.
But the top line, the big story that there
are even legal scholars saying is an impeachable
offense, although it's a question mark for
me.
What do I know?
But really, the top line is Donald Trump knew
how serious Corona virus Corona virus was
back in February, early February.
And he didn't acknowledge it publicly, ostensibly
claiming it's to avoid causing panic.
But we know how that worked out.
Tens of millions of Americans to this day
still don't think this is a serious pandemic
because of that early denial campaign by Donald
Trump.
And meanwhile and tomorrow, I'm going to get
to this.
There's just so much here.
Meanwhile, Donald Trump's approval, in all
likelihood, is going to remain around 45 percent
because something is very wrong with our country.
Donald Trump is admitting, I pretended it
was less serious, which led to more death
than necessary.
And approval is not likely to budge very much.
It's amazing.
It's amazing in terms of the indictment that
it is of our country.
Anybody, in my view, who has not left Donald
Trump already is probably not going to leave
him because of this.
But I don't want to get ahead of myself.
We're going to get into that tomorrow.
Now, meanwhile, you have and we'll discuss
this on the bonus show today.
Donald Trump is arguing that he should be
considered for the Nobel Peace Prize and in
fact, a far right Norwegian politician has
nominated him for it.
On the other hand, we are wondering whether
his handling of Corona virus counts as a crime
against humanity.
That's how desperate the country is right
now on the issue of Donald Trump.
Now, just just one sec.
I want to go back again to the explanation
that is the predominant one in response to
this audio, which is Donald Trump didn't want
to cause panic.
That's a good reason to downplay the virus.
That is barely better, even if you believe
it.
I don't believe it because Donald Trump has
no problem causing panic.
As I said, when he judges, it's politically
advantageous.
Immigrant caravan anarchists in the streets.
Joe Biden's America.
You'll have a depression like you've never
seen before.
Trump is fine, causing panic when it's good
for him.
But imagine that it is true that Donald Trump
didn't want to panic Americans.
We had more death than we needed because Americans
weren't panicked.
In other words, Americans panicking or what
I call taking it more seriously would have
saved lives.
And the next few weeks could see all sorts
of tapes coming out.
There may be more Bob Woodward tapes.
Michael Cohen may have tapes.
There are all sorts of tapes that could be
floating around.
But again, really, will it matter?
Tomorrow on the program, I will argue no.
And we will get to that.
But first, let's talk about some of the other
allegations in Bob Woodward's book.